- I'm actually, like
really straining, here.
(exhales)
(tinfoil tears)
- [Producer] Oh!
- Ah!
(upbeat music)
Hey, what's up, everyone?
My name is Tway and
welcome to "Making it Big,"
the show where my friends challenge me
to make their favorite foods... big.
So, if you notice that my
table is a little warped here,
that's because we're filming
everything with a VR camera.
Very fancy.
If you wanna watch the full VR episode,
you can with a Meta Quest 2 in Mega Tasty.
That's our virtual cooking world
within Horizon World or on Meta Quest TV.
So today, I have my favorite person here.
Soybean!
(both screaming in joy)
Hi! Welcome to the kitchen!
- Excited to be here,
excited to challenge you.
- Let's see what it is.
- To match my outfit, today...
(drum roll)
Takis!
- Did you know that
these were my favorite?
- Maybe a hint or two, but also,
they're one of my favorite chips.
- How big do you want this?
- So knowing you, usually you
like to take the challenge
and up it even more, right?
Big personality, big everything.
But I want you to try to make
this like a baseball bat.
I wanna be able to get
a big swing out of it.
- So, big as a baseball bat.
Fuego, flavor.
- [Producer] Fuego!
- How important is the crunch for you?
- Super important.
That crunch factor needs to be, oof!
'Cuz that's, that's the most
important part of Takis, right?
Like you hear people... (chomping)
- Yeah. All right, thanks but
I have a lot of work to do.
I will see you later,
hopefully, with giant Takis.
- I have faith in you (whispers).
Good job, buddy.
- Thank you.
- Good luck.
- Okay guys, let's make this big.
(whooshing)
All right, giant Takis.
So, that means giant tortilla.
Now, I'm kind of nervous
because I have never made a
tortilla from scratch before.
So, to make a big one is kind of scary.
I have salt, right here.
I have some vegetable oil, here.
So I'm using hot water
because it slows the gluten formation.
It makes the tortilla not puff up.
Like, we don't want this to be bread.
We want this to be a tortilla.
It smells like tamales, right now.
(sniffing)
So, when I moved from Vietnam to America,
we moved to a town called Oxnard.
It was a culture shock that I
didn't know I was going to experience.
Like, I didn't really experience
white culture like that
but I did experience a lot
of Mexican culture because all
of my friends were Mexican.
So, for my first ever
Christmas, I didn't know that,
like tamales was a thing on Christmas.
And now, every year on
Christmas, I have to have tamales
because it's just not the same without it.
Okay, that feels pretty good to me.
I'm gonna... Ooh!
(batter smacking)
Let's get my hands in here.
I think we are ready for an ASMR moment.
(Batter smacking)
(upbeat music)
Okay, so this is the Takis fuego flavor
and I'm looking at the back
of it just to find what
I need for the seasoning.
I think I'm ready to rock and roll.
Let's do our habanero, right here.
Cayenne pepper, garlic powder,
onion powder, paprika, chili powder.
Add some sugar, in here.
I'm really hoping that
all of these powders
and spices will make my
Takis taste like Takis
because that's important.
I need to, I really
need to deliver for Soy.
The citric acid. (whispers)
And again, the reason why
I'm adding this coloring is
because I know that if
I don't, the color's not
going to be vibrant enough and...
Oh, it's getting me. (strained voice)
Now, hold.
(plastic crinkling) (coughing)
- [Producer] Fuego!
- (exhales)
All right, let's get back to work.
It needs to look exactly like the Takis
that you see when you open up the bag.
Ooh, this is probably the
most satisfying moment
for me, to seeing all of the colors.
(coughs)
- [Producer] Fuego!
- Just gonna... (smacking lips)
Ooh, that tastes like a Taki!
All I gotta do now is grind
it up into a finer powder.
(coughs)
Okay.
- [Producer] Fuego! Fuego!
- I'm going through it. (strained voice)
(coughs)
- [Producer] Fuego!
- Oh...
(sneezing)
- [Producer] Fuego!
(Tway laughing)
- If you ever attempt
to make Takis at home,
make sure that you have a mask.
(food processor humming)
Huh?
So, it just doesn't look a like
it's getting to the fine
powder, that I'm looking for.
Because this coating right
here, is really, really fine.
And it's, it's just not
what I'm looking for.
(food processor container clicking)
(exhales loudly)
I have something...
The world's smallest spice grinder.
(playful music)
(spice grinder whirring)
All right.
This is definitely what I'm looking for.
Yeah, that's good stuff!
(upbeat music)
Okay. My dough has been
rested, and I did the math.
This dough right here, will make
approximately six giant Takis.
Perfect!
(wax paper crinkling)
It looks like Patrick
Star, right now. (chuckles)
(wax paper crinkles)
The middle's kind of...
Well, this is not an oval
that I'm hoping for, but
since we're going to be rolling
it, I kind of don't mind it.
It's also my first one.
All right.
This is super delicate.
Be really slow and gentle with it.
I think this is the hardest step.
Ooh!
This is my first giant
Takis, that's gonna go
into the oven at 350 for an hour.
(upbeat music)
All right, so this is our big giant Takis.
Can you guys see me?
This is cooked all the way
through, but it's not crispy.
I need it to really crisp
and have that crunch,
(chomping)
when we bite into it.
So, to the fryer, I go.
(upbeat music)
Here we go!
(drum roll)
Okay. That was really peaceful.
Thank you for that.
The color looks incredible.
(Taki crackling)
- [Crowd] Ooh...!
Here you go.
(upbeat music)
(hollow tapping)
Yep, that feels crunchy.
Here we go!
So, I really want to pack in the powder.
Are you serious?!
Look at this!
It's kind of taking everything
in me right now, to not take a bite.
Let's, let's call Soy and
have her come in sooner,
rather than later, because
this might not be here later.
(upbeat music)
Super proud of what we've created.
I just really hope that Soy loves it.
Soybean!
- Tway, should I opened my eyes?
- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, come here.
- I wanted the surprise factor, you know?
- Yeah.
Okay, ready?
- 3, 2, 1.
(exciting music)
- You got the bag, too?
- Yeah!
- That's crazy!
- Shout out to our department.
Do you want to hold one?
- I would love to hold...
Yeah, as many as I can.
Huh! (laughs)
- I'm gonna get one from me, too.
(flute playing)
A little flute.
So, size?
Did I pass?
- A hundred percent.
Like I feel like I can...
- The looks of it?
- It's like, perfect.
I feel like an ant.
Like, you know when you
see like a giant Taki,
that's what I feel like.
- Yeah.
- That's amazing!
(crunching)
- That crunch!
- That flavor!
- Oh, that is spicy.
- Yeah. I can feel the heat, now.
- [Producer] Fuego!
- The flavor tastes
exactly like the Takis.
Like, I don't know how you did it.
(crunching)
(upbeat music)
(light saber buzzing)
(Soy laughing)
[Soy] Wow! Saving this for later.
Like, look how red our hands are.
- [Tway] This is like, the best, Hmm.
(static)
(door creaking)
(cricket chirping)
(foot steps tapping)
(bag crinkling)
(upbeat music)